we've defined a moment of inertia of a
rigid body already and we'd often are
interested in it because when we rotate
a body about an axis say an axis that's
passing through the center of mass then
our kinetic energy depends on that
moment of inertia through that axis but
we may also want to consider rotation
about another axis so suppose we
consider an axis passing through close
to the end and we rotate the body around
this axis you can see from overhead like
that then we want to now consider how
the mass is distributed about an axis
that was parallel to the axis passing
through the center of mass so we'll now
make a little calculation but first we
want to quote the theorem so let's just
draw an example of our rigid body and
let's take the center of mass and let's
consider an axis that's going
perpendicular to the center of mass we
can think of the object is rotating
about that axis and now let's consider
another axis passing through a different
point but also parallel to this axis
separated by a distance D then the key
result that we want is at the moment of
inertia about an axis passing
perpendicular to the plane of the object
through the axis s is equal to the
moment of inertia about an axis passing
through the center of mass notice these
are parallel axes plus the mass of the
object times the distance between the
two parallel axes and this is a result
that is very useful when calculating
moments of inertia of course we could
calculate the moment about any axis we
wanted and we'll see that in a moment
for example we know that for a rod of
length L that the moment of inertia
through the center of mass was 112 m
that's called the length of Rod L so we
have a length L and let's assume it's a
uniform object and we'll calculate a
moment of inertia through an axis
through the end and so in this case D
is equal to L over two and so I about
the end axis is 1/12 m l squared plus
the mass times L over two squared and
1/12 plus 1/4 is one-third and l squared
and that means that all you need to know
is the moment through the center of mass
and you can calculate the moment through
any other axis very useful theorem
called the parallel axis theorem now as
I said we can calculate the moment about
s and just to show you very quickly if
we pick s here and we pick our little DM
there and we have a distance X then the
moment about s and let's say that DM is
equal to the total mass divided by the
length times some little distance DX
then the moment is DM times x squared
where X will give this an integration
variable X prime goes from 0 to X prime
equals L and so we have for our DM M
over L DX prime remember that's our
integration variable and we have x
squared so that's X prime squared and
this is just the integral of x cubed
over 3 so we have one-third M over L X
prime cubed evaluated from 0 to L and
that comes out to one-third M l squared
and that's in agreement with the
parallel axis theorem and that's an
example of parallel axis theorem you can
do the same thing with the disk or
others or other objects